direction bois d'arcy vendredi dernier
la commune a signé une convention ad
qu'orange pour l'installation de la
fibre optique
c'était l'une des promesses du maire
philippe benassaya
écoutez le on a un gros projet un énorme
projet numérique sur la ville et ce
projet numérique était un petit peu
ralenti du fait qu'on n'avait pas la
fibre à bois d'arcy
le projet c'est le numérique à l'école
la dématérialisation des services sur le
télétravail pour les arcisien et puis
notre zone d'activités de la croix
bonnet qui est déjà fibré mais dont les
habitants n'avaient pas encore bénéficié
de la de la fibre donc on avait un vrai
challenge à relever c'est est
d'accélérer un petit peu ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les autoroutes de
l'information et c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on avait pris une nationale
belle nationale mais on n'était pas
encore sur l'autoroute